what's going on guys this is rob and
with the multiverse coming back
in the marvel cinematic universe so i
guess maybe returning for the first time
i don't really know how we quantify that
but with the multiverse existing now
anything that can happen will happen
and i thought it'd be kind of fun to do
things like phase four and do a
character explanation on like man-gog
and the possibility that we might see a
character like that
in the mcu in phase four i don't know if
we will technically the man-gog
has appeared in the mcu or at least is
tied to the mcu but only because
of the thor god of thunder video game in
2011 but there's two things about that
one that video game sucked so none of us
consider it to be in continuity and two
it's not truly man-dogs so we're gonna
do a character explanation here and just
kind of see how you guys respond to it
the man god first appeared in all comics
with thor issue number 154 back in 1968
and was created by stan lee and jack
kirby now here's one of the things to
understand about the creation of the man
god first and foremost he does have a
definitive origin but later on writers
like jerry conway where thomas people
like that will actually shift it up
especially when we get to
thor number 195 and someone in really
196 and the story is coming after that
but
stan lee as most of you guys know was
really big on allegories and so the
creation of man gog was done for the
purpose to kind of
introduce this concept of what hate
really represents right absolute hatred
absolute anger that it doesn't take on
any kind of an attractive form that it
takes on a very angry form and we know
this from an interview stan lee did
with two morrows publishing where he was
talking about the creation of man gog
and said he wanted a being that
basically personified the ugliness of
hate
so people when they looked at his
comments had to look at what it meant or
see what it meant
to actually embody hate and all the the
the chaos and danger
that it basically brings in of course
kind of paraphrasing here but
nonetheless the whole idea of the
introduction of man gog actually came
out of an existing story that involved a
character named oolak the troll now
those are you guys who are familiar with
thor at the moment you guys have
probably heard of oolak the troll
the reality is he's not nearly as
prominent as he used to be
that's one of the things to know is that
a lot of these characters that you see
in the thor mythos kind of off and on
right looking at characters like ooh
like the troll people like hella even or
possibly even certain
they were huge mainstays of the thor
mythos back during the 60s 70s and 80s
but over time they started dropping off
in popularity as marvel made way for
other stories some of which were more
cerebral some of which were more basic
but action-packed but regardless a lot
of those characters began to drop off
but when you look at the character of
oula control the way this played out
is that in thor issue number 153 he had
found himself in a fight with thor
which basically took place in a in a
realm called nornheim now ultimately
ula control was defeated and then cast
down into a place called the abyss of
shadows now the abyss of shadows was
essentially a death sentence right like
if he fell down into it that was
essentially the end of you but along the
way oola control actually latched onto
an
edge and found himself in front of
something called the cave of ages
now stan lee actually ended up taking a
page out of his own book and what i mean
by that is when oolak the troll gets to
the cave of ages he discovers this giant
rock with an inscription on the front
and the inscription reads
let no living being disturb what lies
within by order of imperial odin and
this was basically
stan lee referencing his own work from
three years prior in 1965 with x-men
issue number 12
and the introduction of the juggernaut
right a lot of you guys know that origin
story kane marcos sees the crimson gem
of sidorak and it has an inscription
the inscription of course reads
whosoever touches this gem shall possess
the power of the crimson bands of
cenorak henceforth you who read these
words shall become forevermore
a human juggernaut so it's basically
stan lee just kind of building up on his
own work which i think is kind of a cool
thing here but ooh like the troll
basically looks at this from the
perspective of saying okay
basically i can ally myself with this
being whoever this happens to be behind
this thing and if it was locked away by
odin it must be something exceedingly
powerful
which is certainly capable enough to
destroy asgard and everybody on it since
of course oh look the troll was always
looking to bring down asgard and so what
ends up happening is when he frees or
really unlocks this
this uh this kind of rock that it leads
to the man god popping up now this is
when the origin of the man gog gets a
little finicky because when he first
shows up here he says let the universe
tremble the man god lives again i have
one goal
one aim one destiny to destroy him who
crushed the invasion of my race
after which he denies oola control any
chance of working together basically
stating that his whole goal is to
essentially destroy odin any of his
followers and even goes as far as to say
that he's a foe of all those who live
right so his aspirations to inflict the
destruction of things
extend beyond asgard and seemingly to
all of reality itself
overcomes ulik and then just kind of
goes from there now once you actually
get to mangog himself who launches an
invasion against asgard this takes place
at the time that odin is in the odin
sleep now for those of you guys who are
not familiar with that the odin sleep
was basically introduced to marvel
comics as a way for marvel to have this
concept
where sometimes asgard would be
defenseless because back during the 60s
70s and 80s odin was really given to us
as just kind of like this nigh
unstoppable entity now there were a few
stories here and there for example when
you had the
uh the third celestial host where the
celestials came down to earth and then
you had like the destroyer armor
assembled by odin and the rest of the
sky fathers which was obliterated you
had a few instances like that where it
was shown that odin was not nigh
unstoppable but for the most part in
comparison to most all the other stories
that you saw
odin was this being that just couldn't
really be defeated by seemingly anybody
on earth it would take an insane level
of power to pull that off and so where
ullah control
and man god basically work together
temporarily in order for
for man god to basically make his escape
one of the things that was kind of crazy
here is that ullah comes to the
realization
that in freeing man gog he took off more
than he could handle and even goes as
far as to say
better i had perished than to set the
man gog free
he says in all the spinning cosmos there
can be no safety now right which
basically said you know really gave it
give it to us as the reader that once
man gog is out there's really no
stopping him and that was one of the
things that stan lee solidified
right off the bat when it came to the
introduction of man god right this guy
goes forward
into asgard and just lays waste to
everyone like no one's able to stop him
right i mean it takes whole teams
but it takes you all these asgardian
warriors to do what they can to fend off
against uh against man gog
and he overcomes them all and eventually
makes his way into the
the inner chamber of where odin resides
with the intention of attaining the odin
sword now
one of the things that have been hit on
a lot in marvel comics at the time to
kind of sidetrack from this for a second
especially when you went and you read
the tales of asgard stories by jack
kirby which were basically backup
features in the old thor stories
is that if anybody ever drew the odin
sword then it would basically lead to
ragnarok right it would start the cycle
of essentially destroying the entirety
of asgard
and the end of everything and marvel
toyed with that a lot it wasn't really
until you got to walt simonson's store
run that you saw the first real
indication of ragnarok
actually happening in marvel and then of
course you saw it in the thor
disassembled storyline
up until this point and even during this
story itself it was always one of these
things where it was like is it going to
be ragnarok this time you know and then
of course basically the day was saved
and it wasn't but thor himself
is overcome by the power of man gog
nothing can really stop this guy and
every single member of like the warriors
three right so thor's inner circle uh
all these guys every asgardian warrior
falls before man god now this ultimately
gets to the point where mangog himself
essentially accesses the odin sword with
the intention of pulling it out
and then using it to bring about the end
of all asgardians now of course as you
would expect
odin basically wakes up and essentially
saves the day and does this by freezing
the limbs of
mangogog basically keeping him in place
and then revealing the reality of what
happened
this is where his origin again kind of
circling around to the murkiness of it
all this is when you find out what
supposedly actually happened but yet
again
it'll be changed later in marvel so the
explanation that's given to us by odin
is that instead of him actually killing
the entire race of man god
instead what had happened is he had
taken the entire race basically all
their energy
and put it inside of what was basically
a containment unit which took the form
of mangog and then
imprisoned him away now one of the
things that was kind of interesting here
is that over the years when you looked
at this
mangog for the most part was one of
these characters that didn't appear a
whole lot despite being a guy who
in his first appearance was enough to
overpower everybody in asgard with the
exception of odin who basically
dissipated his essence across the cosmos
man god hasn't appeared all that much
but one of the things that was really a
big deal here is that despite being
defeated and basically the
desire of his hate right the existence
of this hatred of this alien race for
odin
basically being stopped that man gog
essentially didn't serve
any real useful purpose he wasn't really
supposed to exist anymore but one of the
things that happened is that marvel
ended up bringing him back now this of
course took place in thor 195 in 1972
and by this point the stories have been
written by jerry conway now i can't
really find
an interview as to why it is conway
decided to bring the man
god back presumably because of the fact
that the man god when he was first
brought in by stan lee and jack kirby
was of just such an insurmountable force
against the asgardians
it would just be cool to have him back
the problem with this was finding a way
to bring him back if the whole idea
behind his existence
is that the hatred of the alien race
that had basically been
destroyed or confined by odin was
essentially dissipated because now there
was no need for him anymore and so what
ended up happening is that in 195
loki actually set man god free and that
in turn odin
offered an explanation to the various
asgardians and essentially revealed here
that the very evil
that powered man gog essentially has to
exist i.e
man-gog is in effect a force of nature
so long as there is evil that exists in
the
in the universe man gog will continue to
exist now one of the things that's kind
of interesting here if you sort of read
between the lines a little bit a lot of
this is just kind of based on our
interpretation of it
you can essentially look at this idea
and state that if odin had basically
defeated or captured or destroyed
an alien race and then took their
spiritual essence and confined it within
uh what basically became mangog that
even when they were freed that he
unwittingly created a kind of bond
between man gog
and the emotional aspect of hatred anger
fear different things along those lines
and so long as those exist
man god will always exist now of course
over the course of the story going into
196 through 197
man god did exactly what he did before
which was to absolutely
lay waste to the entirety of asgard the
problem with this is that depending on
who you talk to
some people loved the events of in the
shadow of the man gog
other people hated it right it's one of
these stories where it kind of splits
the community but one of the things that
people cannot really deny is that these
early appearances of mangog
had him as an absolute boss right this
guy would just crush
asgard and it's one of these things
where even in these early stories it was
solidified that asgard
couldn't defeat mangog on their own did
they grab different giants that were out
there they even worked with hella at one
point in time
that there were these different
situations where when man gog showed up
it took
basically pulling out all the stops to
bring an end to these guys and it's one
of these things where you got these
small little moments here and there
where
for example man gog was powered with the
hate of a billion billion beings right
just different things along those lines
but having said that the confusion that
existed
in terms of how man god could exist with
this race having basically been returned
and all that kind of stuff
was solved in thor issue number 198 when
jerry conway took
everything and just wrapped it all
together both the work of stanley and
jack kirby as well as the work of
himself
and essentially revealed here that yes
man gog is powered by the hatred
of the beings that were by all standards
of measurement destroyed but the
important thing here is despite the fact
that they had been returned
they still hated odin and so he was
still powered by that hate and so
whether or not those beings had
basically been destroyed and their hate
had essentially
manifested in the form of man gog
himself or they were still alive that
hatred would still exist and so long as
it exists
man gog would exist now the whole point
behind jerry conway doing this again i
couldn't really find a definitive
interview but i kind of have to believe
this was the case
the whole point of doing this was to
basically create a kind of end run so
there'd always be a means by which
man god could return and the reason why
was because in these early appearances
one of the things that was solidified is
that man gog
did have the ability to tap into magical
energy he could shapeshift so on and so
forth but more than anything he was just
an overwhelming force that could never
actually be destroyed hence the reason
that odin made the statement that he
could never actually destroy
mangogog himself because he basically
has to exist at this point he's a force
of nature it would take somebody on a
much higher level of power who in all
honesty would not really have any
interest in destroying the man gog now
having said all of that the question
that you might find yourself asking here
is that if the manga was was introduced
as
a credible threat to asgard so much so
that even odin was afraid of him
and was just kind of this powerhouse
then why did marvel stop writing stories
about it right why didn't he necessarily
appear that much why is it that he
appeared
11 times over the course of those those
you know original thor stories
and then just kind of faded into
oblivion at basically a fever pitch
the reason for that is one of the things
we've talked about before is that
following 1971 a lot of people point to
the dark knight returns at dc comics as
kind of the starting point of the bronze
age where stories became darker and more
cerebral
focusing more on character-driven
stories as opposed to just crazy events
happening
i really point more towards 1971 with
the night when stacy died the first time
in really comic book history that you
saw an instance where a love interest of
a superhero died
not because somebody else killed her in
the same way that like eobard thon
killed
iris west in the 1970s in the flash
comics but by the superhero's
own failure which was spider-man's
mistake then that basically changed
everything in comics and so you started
seeing things going forward where it was
focusing again more on cerebral stories
focusing more on character-driven
stories and less on things like here
comes the man-gog
not only that because the man-god was a
character that had been written a
certain way by stan lee and jack kirby
as well as jerry conway there wasn't
really a whole lot of drive to correct
that there wasn't really a whole lot of
drive
to write him in a more interesting and
intriguing way and so that's why
over the years if you look at things
like thor volume 2 issues 21 through 25
where you look at issue number 84 or you
go back and you look at the thunder
strike series thunderstrike volume 2
issue number five you have these
appearances by man gog that are small
time right where he just kind of pops up
for a little bit and then it's just
almost immediately defeated and it's
always like well you know so long as
hatred will endure i will always endure
and that's basically it right he's just
kind of and a lot of ways treated like a
punching bag and truth to tell
that pisses off man god fans because
while man god doesn't really have
a lot of fans out there the fans he does
have love him and it's one of the things
where they just kind of get pissed at
the idea that marvel just sort of throws
him out there and nothing ever really
happens with him especially because of
the fact that he was a guy that scared
the piss out of odin back in the day
in in marvel comics and so more recently
with man gog and it's something that we
covered under jason aaron's thor run
which i still consider to be the
greatest thor run of all time
but one of the things that had happened
more recently is you saw man gog
returning really at the tail end of the
series
facing off against jane foster and this
wasn't really designed to give us
man gog as we were used to which was a
just massive credible threat that would
call together
really not just thor and the asgardians
but probably a whole host of forces
from across the different realms as well
as probably the avengers on earth
instead it was really more of a story
designed to complement and really focus
on the character of jane foster
that man gog was given as a way to kind
of be a physical manifestation
of how much everybody hated jane foster
and that her
overcoming the man gog was her
overcoming everybody's hatred of her i.e
jason aaron saying sorry about your luck
but she's not going anywhere of course
she did they basically ended the thor
story and then she ended up becoming
valkyrie so
you know one of the things that i always
said during that time is give it a while
odin's son will go back to being thor
again nobody wanted to believe it would
happen
but it always does in comics that's the
nature of comics is always kind of going
in a cyclical pattern but the important
thing here is last we saw man god
basically he was thrown into the sun
and whether or not anything significant
really comes out of that
we don't know it's one of these things
where man gog was defeated and then at
some point we'll likely end up coming
back
and that's going to be the end of it but
that's one of the things is that man gog
was always just this incredible host of
a character who ended up being turned
into more or less a plot device
and a punching bag for whatever
particular story was being written by
that particular writer at the time so
again you know that kind of happens in
marvel comics and it happens a lot more
often than you would like to believe
that you have these characters that are
introduced as just like these insanely
powerful beings
and then are just kind of throwaway
characters after that and just kind of
get beat up on
and that's basically it and they seem
like a shadow of their former selves
in terms of the power they possess but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
you